I didn't think Lance told anybody he
didn't do anything to me
the only good for me he raised five
hundred million dollars for cancer
research that's what that lied did
everybody had the bands on right oh yeah
that blocked out the Sun yeah you know
it wasn't cancer yeah it was annoyed and
I hated how Oprah was interviewing him
and acting like she was dumbfounded that
this guy would do this like she's been
in show business for 35 years and she
can't like wrap her head around some guy
doing whatever it takes to get to the
next level
didn't she for the first five years have
liked midgets who wanted to bang them
mailman's boyfriend and she didn't want
to do it she didn't want to do it but
she didn't have the power to say no so
she wrote it out and then when she could
make a good decision she did a show but
she stood on the heads of those little
people
[Applause]
look the guy was the sociopath on a
bicycle all right search week we got up
easy yeah if that guy was working for a
corporation he probably would have been
porn stuff in the water supply doing
god-knows-what just keep him on the bike
the top 20 guys like all tested positive
Lloyd so I roided-up guy beat your
roided-up guy who run that filthy sport
ridiculous he doesn't represent cycling
are they gonna return all the money that
they made off of that guy huh they're
gonna turn in their yachts they're not
gonna they're not gonna do it everyone
turn in your yacht